[Musique]
voilà donc bienvenue à la télé
une oeuvre comment elle fonctionne c'est
qu'elle prend tes yeux
elle prend ton corps et après s'être
cantonnés les oeuvres de manuel mathieu
seront en vedette dans les plus
prestigieuses galeries musées du pays
cet automne un succès phénoménal pour
cet artiste montréalais originaire
d'haïti
le cousin de mon père mort et benjamins
qui m'a introduit alors j'avais à peu
près 15 ans j'étais fasciné par le fait
que les artistes puissent vivre de ce
qui crée dans leur nom leur âme à 15 ans
et révolutionnaire à 19 ans il vient
étudier à montréal avant de poursuivre
sa maîtrise à l'université gaulle smit à
londres ou en 2015
il est victime d'un grave accident de la
route ou là une épiphanie par rapport à
sa démarche artistique
je me suis retrouvé dans une situation
je me posais des questions sur qu'est-ce
que je peux faire qui m'appartient et
qui serait vraiment unique
lorsque j'ai creusé j'ai compris que on
sorte acheminant 86 et c'est l'année la
dictature a pris fin on a tout à fait
normal que il ya un résidu il ya une
queue de cette date là que de la
dictature est toujours là ça m'a
vraiment capté haïti ses racines restent
au coeur de son inspiration leucisme de
2010 à d'ailleurs été un autre élément
fondateur dans sa pratique
je n'ai pas fait de manière directe je
travaille sur la vulnérabilité sur
l'amnésie j'ai travaillé sur la solitude
aussi donc c'est les concepts qui
m'intéresse et qui qui font leur chemin
de mon travail et aujourd'hui je
travaille sur sur le désir avant
d'atteindre la reconnaissance au canada
il s'est illustré à l'étranger et les
collectionneurs s'arrachent ses toiles
partout sur la planète et ses oeuvres se
vendre plusieurs dizaines de milliers de
dollars
donc manuel n'est plus dans une
dynamique locale est vraiment la
dynamique internationale avec des prix
qu'ils ont fait appel de son vivant
connu si on peut comparer un talent rare
selon l'équipe du musée des beaux-arts
qui lui consacrera une expo solo à la
rentrée et qui récemment acheté une de
ses toiles
il a choisi d'utiliser son cachet pour
la création d'un fonds pour l'achat
d'oeuvres d'artistes issus de la
diversité
mais l'artiste impôts est déjà une
personne qui vit dans le monde de la
poésie puisqu'il reflète certaines
choses
il partage son intimité il cherche une
recherche inspirante pour un artiste
fascinant est à découvrir ici nabi
alexandre charte si radio canada
montréal